l'été frappa nos portes les touristes
sont de retour dans le vieux Montréal
c'est la course pour trouver des
employés on a reçu beaucoup de CV
mais malheureusement quand l'appel oui
on vient mais ne vient jamais où il
trouve quelque chose
mieux que que
de nombreux restaurateurs mis sur les
étudiants pour combler les postes
vacants
ici on cherche des plongeurs et des
cuisiniers mais les candidats ne se
bousculent pas entrer dans une cuisine
qui fait très chaud c'est pas du travail
facile c'est sûr alors des fois c'est un
peu difficile à comprendre le rêve de la
cuisine convaincre le monde de
travailler le vendredi samedi soir et
jours fériés c'est un peu difficile
j'ai travaillé cet été une figure pas
dans les plans de certains étudiants
ceux qui cherchent un emploi au
l'embarras du choix ils ont des attentes
une bonne paye pour être honnête avec
vous comme je vais faire de l'argent et
tout ça commence le célèbre puis on veut
profiter de profiter de notre jeunesse
encore un peu avec une réflexive c'est
plus important comme ça je peux avoir du
temps pour avoir des passe-temps et tout
dans la vie il faut avoir du temps pour
travailler du temps pour ça même tu as
compris et la même chose c'est l'argent
les 15 jours de l'organisme sésame
accueille 500 jeunes chaque été dans le
Grand Montréal cette année il manque
encore quelques moniteurs pour combler
les besoins
effacer tellement longtemps mais un
salaire bonifié n'est pas toujours
suffisant et c'est vraiment flexible
[Musique]
du coup mais des fois leur permet de
travailler 25 20 il faut aussi mettre en
valeur les avantages sociaux et après
ton quart de travail tu vas pouvoir
aussi sortir avec tes amis on 5 à 7 on
sort entre amis on va dans des
restaurants fixés aussi leur montrer que
même s'ils travaillent pendant l'été ça
va être un été où ils vont aussi
s'amuser
pour 20 emplois puisqu'on pouvait dicter
nos règles en tant qu'employeur ça a
disparu ça dans l'ensemble des camps de
vacances et des 40 jours la souplesse
est devenue la clé pour satisfaire les
attentes des jeunes employés et beaucoup
qui avaient des demandes à pas vouloir
une semaine de vacances pendant l'été
alors que traditionnellement c'est tout
engagé pour les 9 10 semaines comme
animateur puis c'était tu posais pas de
question bah il y a eu de l'ouverture il
y a eu des changements et puisque la
concurrence est féroce les employeurs
doivent développer une stratégie de
recrutement agressive
le Zoo de Granby diffuse des publicités
qui ciblent les jeunes sur des réseaux
sociaux comme Tik Tok et Instagram on a
aussi fait une tournée des écoles de la
région armée de cette affiche et je ne
pouvait directement scanner le code QR
toute l'information pour après ça avoir
accès à notre porte ouverte ça nous
donne le texto pour après ça pouvoir les
contacter c'est le fun parce qu'on peut
le communiquer directement et la journée
même il semble s'ils sont retenus ou pas
au zoo donc qui ont un contact très
direct c'est rapide et comme ça on peut
les sécuriser le versus d'autres
entreprises comme d'autres employeurs le
zoo offre un peu plus que le salaire
minimum est de petites primes aux jeunes
qui reviennent travailler d'année en
année on leur permet également de
travailler à temps partiel et de prendre
des vacances résultat il faut embaucher
davantage de personnel avant on tournait
autour de 500 étudiants maintenant on
dépense le 600 étudiants en 630 650
étudiants donc c'est quand même une
grosse différence là versus il y a 4,50
par exemple et je ne veux le profiter
aussi de leur été c'est très correct
donc on doit être on doit être à
l'écoute de leurs besoins puis être plus
flexible les employeurs n'ont pas le
choix dans la jungle il faut s'adapter
pour survivre